the manhunt is under way in Pennsylvania
this morning for the suspected killer of
a police officer
investigators say 29 year old women saw
Holt is armed and dangerous he's accused
of killing 25 year old police officer
Brian Shaw Friday night after a traffic
stop Don Dahler is outside the New
Kensington police station that's
northeast of Pittsburgh Don good morning
good morning family and friends will
have an opportunity to pay their
respects to officer Moore today officer
saw excuse me today and tomorrow during
a viewing the funeral is scheduled for
Wednesday the reward for information
leading to the capture of the suspect
now stands at more than 43 thousand
dollars we will find you we will arrest
you and we will prosecute you so that
you were held accountable for what has
occurred Police Chief Jim Kline had a
pointed message for the man they believe
gunned down their brother in blue during
a traffic stop Friday night rahmel Sal
Holtz got out of his car and police say
he ran from rookie officer Brian Shaw at
some point during the foot pursuit shots
were fired Shaw was shot in the chest
and died from his wounds despite wearing
a bulletproof vest shortly after the
shooting heavily armed officers filled
the streets of this New Kensington
neighborhood looking for the suspect
everyone's still in shock still scared
see what's gonna happen if they catch
the guy hold has a criminal record
reportedly dating back to 2007 which
includes firearm and drug convictions on
Saturday fellow police and emergency
responders led a funeral procession for
officer Shaw's body he was on the force
for less than six months officer Shaw
was a very young man I had a wonderful
family and they're just trying to go
through the grieving process and deal
with the world win of tragedy that just
struck their family police are not
saying why the suspect was pulled over
nor why he ran the officers here are
being filled in by officers from other
areas other departments in neighboring
communities so that the New Kensington
officers
can warn Gail heartbreaking story thank
you very much Don